I didn't know crypto was down until I  asked because that's the ethernet doing  what is what is it called oh no ethereum  [Laughter]  the court is the is the core they put in  their computers in the internet close  and they're related you need one for the  other there you go  Sam Marty  I don't know [ __ ] all right so there we  go you guys genuinely saw it right  now.com sign up for tickets see this is  why rant City doesn't happen so for  everyone out on the ethernet like I  can't be saying that [ __ ] in Ted Talk I  gotta get seasoned with the technology  somewhat I can't just talk about packs  um  or maybe I can I don't [ __ ] care it's  got me this far yeah okay I don't care  [Music]